it's like going to a rock concert it's
like you know that you're going to hear
somebody speak what do you get from a
lecturer that you don't get in the book
presence power excitement participation
right this is why rock stars are always
confused when they introduce new songs
on tour and people cry out for the old
regulars they want to experience the
rush the power right so when Bill
Clinton came to campus when you know a
Barack Obama comes to town or the dalai
lama comes to campus people who need to
be there are demonstrating religiousness
taipei because religiousness taipei is
participation in power and the Dali Lama
radiates presence and power does this
mean that people are going to become
Tibetan Buddhists no nobody's interested
in the Theravada they're interested in
the Sun I mean this and artistry and the
mandala and the X the esoteric character
the exotica of the Dali Lama but most of
all it's an event it's a happening and
whenever people think in terms of
happening rather than in terms of how
can I be a better person today how can I
be a better teacher how can I be a
better whatever then they're
demonstrating religiousness a so that's
that's what's going on with the Dalai
Lama
oh I'm sure but if they chatted with the
Dalai Lama they didn't chat with him
about theology the Dalai Lama is not a
theologian he's you know he exemplifies
in his subjectivity the Dalai Lama
exhibits type three that is the type of
internal purification through Theravada
Buddhism right the annihilation of the
self and so forth and so on
phenomenologically he is an instrument
of Taipei he's a rock star when he comes
to town everything shifts right so when
the president comes to any town or city
in this country its power power
displaces so motorcades streets are
blocked schedules are changed right and
everything organizes around the
perception of power maybe not ultimate
power but pretty close why do you want
to crash a White House dinner party
access to power what does access powered
power give you higher status in the
reality TV game so it's you know this is
how isn't this fun you know religious
studies is so fascinating because you
know being religious is such a
fundamental way of being human and if we
can get the right categories of how to
analyze religious behavior we have one
of the great instruments for
understanding human behavior that's not
simply reducible to economic are
predictors because religious behavior
manifests itself quite apart from I
think social determinism so you find
highly educated people getting giddy
with the thought of being in the
presence of a powerful religious figure
you